احنا انتقلنا من جدار القبله اللي هو
الرواق الاول الى الرواق الثالث وصلنا
للمحراب السليماني طبعا احنا دائما نتوقع
انه المحراب يكون في جدار القبله بس لكن
هذا المحراب في الجدار الثالث اكيد عندك
معلومات بتحب تحكي لنا عنها
السليماني او المحراب الحنفي من المعالم
الاساسيه في المسجد النبوي الشريف وهو
سليماني مع انه هو انشئ قبل سلطان سليمان
القانوني ينشا طوفان باشا خلال الفتره
المملوكيه المتاخره قبل وبالتالي تم
اختيار هذا المكان بعنايه بعنايه اولا ان
يكون بمحاذاه المنبر النبوي الشريف انه هو
جدار المسجد النبوي الشريف الاساسي وليس
في جدار القبله صحيح لانه هذه التوسعه
حصلت ايام عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
بعده عثمان بن رضي الله عنهم فهذا
الاختيار الاختيار حكيم جدا ودقيق جدا هذا
الاول انه اختاروا على الامتداد المحراب
النبوي الشديد الامر الاخر انه جعله متوسط
المسجد لانه دائما المسجد النبوي الشريف
من توسعات الاولى للنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم المحراب لم يكن متوسطا نعم وانما هذه
واحده من صفات المسجد انتبهوا الشريف عدم
توسط الامام لان المحراب ثابت في عدد
المكان وهو توقيفي وحتما فجاء هذا
المحراب وتم اغتياله ليتوسط ان
اختيارين اساسيين طيب ليش تعددت المحاريب
لانه الى عهد السلطان عبد الملك عبد
العزيز يعني يرحمه الله كان الائمه على
المذاهب المختلفه يصلون بالناس كل متعب
يصلي على محراب فهذا كان المحراب الاساسي
هو المحراب النبوي وكان الامام الراتب
اللي هو الامام الشافعي الشافعي يصلي في
المحراب معظم الصلوات واخذ التشكيل هذا
لانه نشوف نلاحظ ان المحراب هذا يعني
التكوين مملوكي شبيه شبيه لكن ليس مثل
اتقان ودقه المسجد باحراب النبوي الشريف
وانما هو ياخذ نفس التكوين نفس الهيئه نفس
النسب
الفراغيه او اجمالا محراب مملوكي مع
تعديلات عثمانيه عليه تعديلات العثمانيه
اواسط القرن السادس
هجري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات